SPEAKER: Hi.
I'm Alicia.
And today, I'm going to discuss
who citizen developers are
and why they're able
to digitally transform
their work with AppSheet.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The demand for citizen
developers is on the rise,
with an estimated
2 billion people
who can benefit
from this skill set.
But what exactly is
a citizen developer?
In short, they're are
the people closest
to the problem who've been
empowered to find or create
a solution.
In order for these
individuals to be empowered,
they need access
to technology that
is democratized in
nature while preventing
the use of non-IT-sanctioned
third party platforms,
also known as shadow IT.
Google Cloud's no-code platform
AppSheet provides just that.
It allows anyone the
access and ability
to create applications
within the framework provided
by their IT team.
Let's walk through
a quick example.
Meet Annie, an operational lead
for a manufacturing company.
Annie has been
receiving feedback
that the current inspection
practice is inefficient
and impacting the
customer experience.
Workers want a mobile
solution, but her IT team
doesn't have the time
to build an application.
She needs something custom and
she needs to find it quickly.
Annie discovers AppSheet,
a no-code platform
that can help her create an
application in days or weeks,
rather than months or years.
When working with
the platform, she
discovers that there are
governance capabilities
and she's able to
work with her IT team
to put the right
policies in place that
can prevent shadow IT.
She builds an app
within this framework
and shares it with
her colleagues
on the manufacturing floor,
iterating with feedback
until she's built the right
solution for the need.
Not only has Annie
helped her team,
but she's obtained the valuable
skill set of building apps
with no-code.
This means that in addition
to being an operations lead,
she can now count
herself among the growing
group of citizen developers.
Other departments
soon take notice
of how quickly Annie was able to
solve the problem with no-code.
Since IT has already provided
governance guidelines,
other teams are able to start
leveraging AppSheet, becoming
citizen developers themselves.
And it's not just
operations leaders
who benefit from
citizen development.
Accountants, teachers,
IT professionals,
and more have all enlisted
no-code technology to digitally
transform their work with custom
line of business solutions,
like Annie's.
Ready to start your
citizen developer journey?
Get started today by clicking
the link in the description
below.
Happy app building.
[MUSIC PLAYING]